i had this thought oh this is what it
would have been like to talk to bill
gates at 21.
yeah i feel like i could rule the world
i know i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
so this episode is gonna be it might be
shorter than normal right
yeah i think so okay i wanted
i just drove uh like 30 hours and i
listened
to a ton of content i want to tell you
sean about some of the stuff that i
listen to and why it's interesting is
that what you want to do
for this entire episode yeah let's do it
and i'm sure you'll have some stuff
um uh that you've consumed okay the
first one
i found this podcast that has like
actually let's see how many reviews
i think like no reviews i think i
emailed the guy he's amazing
but uh it's called how to take over the
world
we should just have this guy we should
just absorb this guy's
uh podcast we need to acquire this guy's
podcast this should just be on our feed
wait did you did you listen to it no i'm
just looking at the description of it
and then the
gems that you just told me and i'm like
this should be part of mfm this is great
it's amazing this guy he uh he it's like
his
hobby and he really he they're so
in-depth so it's called how to take over
the world
what i think he's doing is you know a
lot of biographies of great people like
napoleon
uh julius caesar the raw child they're
like 800 to a thousand pages so it's
like a real commitment to read it
so he just reads it and he takes notes
in one episode he did one on napoli and
he goes i have 60 paper thomas edison he
goes i have 60 pages of notes
and he just reads the book and takes
notes and then just explains and tells
stories from the book and does it in
chronological chronological order and
it's
basically turns if you listen to a
thousand page book on audio on audible
it's something like 40 or 50 hours but
with him i just listened to this
two-hour podcast and i feel like i've
just read most of the book it's pretty
amazing
but he also gives his analysis about it
and so i listened to a few of them i
listened to one on edison
one on napoleon and one of the
rothschild rothschilds
and there's three commonalities that i
want to tell you about these guys
so do you know who rothschild is
rothschild am i saying that right
yeah so basically it was started by this
guy named
angel rothschild in the 1700s he
basically built like the amazon
of of this his little ghetto in in
germany where he would sell like he
would mail you an item and if you wanted
it you would send him money
and it wasn't like that big but
eventually he started
he grew that over 50 years and started
investing in stuff and then his kids
started the goldman sachs of
of europe so it was like a long uh slow
build up to building this family
business
so i'm gonna tell you three things that
i've noticed that these folks had in
common the first
all of them enjoyed their work so
there's a story where nathan rothschild
this um this one woman was talking to
him he's like
you know i hope you better hope that
your kids aren't addicted to work like
you are and he goes
oh no i hope they are because i love
what i'm doing and i don't ever want to
stop
uh same with napoleon someone said
napoleon what
what's your heritage what race are you
he goes i'm of the race of men who found
empires
[Laughter]
uh like they're addicted to it like they
love it they they can't
they can't not do it same with edison
edison he was like nice to his kids and
nice to his wife but he was really never
around
and they called he called his um uh his
studio which was in menlo park
i believe it's called miller park in new
jersey and they said that it looked like
a homeless
encampment because there's these men in
suits but they were just like laying
around on the floor and sleeping there
because they would do their best work
from midnight to 6 a.m
and they would just sleep below under
their desk and they're like well why are
you doing this he's like
because there's so much to do and we
love it like we can't not do this
so they all enjoyed their work the
second thing crazy
crazy high energy so super high energy
so the napoleon he went to egypt to go
conquer something and on his way he
stopped in like
some island where he like reorganized
the government in three weeks and he
and he changed their currency just they
all have crazy high energy
and that's something that i didn't
actually think was a big deal but they
all had crazy
high energy now here's the third thing
that i found to be kind of interesting
a lot of the successful people that i'm
learning about on this podcast they eat
very very very little
so like edison would only drink milk
sometimes for months steve jobs
for months for months milk
steve dude do you remember steve jobs
how he had a fruit
yeah i was gonna say he's a fruitarian
or whatever it was the same thing he
used to only eat like
lunch and it was just fruit you know or
something like that for a period of time
rockefeller or rockefeller and
vanderbilt were this way too
like in their first in like the it was
it's all when they're all described
like look he ate very little typically
didn't eat breakfast ate very little
they're all like physically hungry and
that physical hungry hunger
some it does actually seem like it leads
to some type of like success
does that so so um yeah okay so let me
give you my take on all three of these
so you said
uh they really enjoyed their work like
their work feels like plays the way i
would
describe it where they didn't feel like
they were forcing themselves to do
something they
couldn't wait to go keep doing it i
would also say there's an obsession
there now like it's like
i'm obsessed with stuff like is that do
i enjoy it i don't know if i enjoy it
but like i
the ocd forces you there's an obsession
so there's a conor mcgregor fight this
saturday
and he has a great kind of like
monologue from back when he was a nobody
but he was talking about it he goes
he goes i've lost my mind to this game
he goes i think you must do that i think
you must become obsessed
you want to lose your mind to your craft
and
i've seen that as like a common thing
for a lot of people and and that
actually relates to the eight very
little a lot of time you get so
engrossed
in what you're doing that you just
forget to eat you forget to go to the
restroom you forget what time it is you
forget the cl you know what you should
sleep or you forget to
pay that bill because you become
completely obsessed and
engrossed in what you're doing and you
get in in a flow state really
and in a flow state you um you sort of
block out a lot of the other stuff
that's going on
and so i think that's that's those two
sort of go hand in hand
um and then the high energy i'm curious
what that means to you so that's like
it doesn't mean like you're bouncing off
the walls right yeah that's what i
imagine what did you mean
no it doesn't mean that you're bouncing
off the walls but for example when i go
and when i'm at a conference um
like let's say it's my conference or
let's say it's uh at our at our talk
that we did the other day how did you
feel at the end of that
the live shows yeah uh i felt
kind of drained i felt drained i felt
exhausted
yeah but what i think like what i think
high energy means is
i felt just so worn out then but i think
that some people they would feel
good and they'd be like all right let's
go like get some more deals done let's
go invest like
like like i invest a little bit of money
but if i was a full-time investor
you're doing deals all day and for me
by like four or five o'clock i'm like
ugh i can't talk to another person i'm
exhausted i can't think about this
anymore
but i've seen some people that can do it
all day and they just aren't worn out
and they just keep going and going and
going and going
right that's what i mean yeah i i'm with
you on that um
yeah okay i think this is cool and i
like the um the study
of of the sort of study of greatness and
what i've also found is that like
we've talked about this before it's like
would you want to be elon musk would you
want to be
like basically this stuff comes at a
pretty big sacrifice
um for other things in life family
often um you know relationships you know
it's hard to relate to people or spend
time with friends or anything like that
if you're doing this
so when you so i'm like you i like
digesting these i like
knowing it but then over time i've
learned that like
the goal is not to be steve jobs or a
collective jobs or anything i just kind
of am fascinated by it
in the same way that like i'm fascinated
about how you know a rhinoceros
moves and eats and i don't necessarily
want to be a rhinoceros i just
find it interesting that it's extreme
creature i love
freaks i like the freak show and these
guys are freak shows i also love bold
people i admire anyone who's bold so for
example
i was reading a book about steve mcqueen
he was just an actor like he didn't
change the world he probably didn't work
that hard but he was like known for like
saying his opinion and he like lived a
very like free life
that and it's like in the same field i
like these people i like men who will
who do what they say and they say like
things that are different than other
people but then also i love these freak
shows like napoleon
now let's actually talk about each of
these thomas edison like elon
a bunch of divorces one of his wives
died from a morphine overdose his kids
didn't really like him or get to know
him that well even though he was like a
kind guy but he was never around
napoleon died on an island because they
kicked him out and he died basically
with nothing alone in an island off the
coast of africa
rothschild um he
the the the i mean they were okay they
actually had good ideas
but um with a lot of successful people
like this
yeah you don't actually want to be them
necessarily yeah um
okay so what else uh what else you got
so you consume that what else you
consume
okay have you read uh naval's almanac
yeah shout out to um jack butcher no no
uh uh eric right eric i think jorgensen
is the last name yeah he was the main
guy and jack
animated whatever yeah oh there it is so
naval has uh so it's a two-part i
actually don't
know how it came to be did naval just do
a bunch of podcasts and interviews and
he summarized naval's feelings
yeah basically so neval had been putting
out his content for years
different podcasts and stuff like that
and a lot people like me and eric and
others were
big fans of it and what he did was he
said all right uh
you i don't know if you've ever bought
the book or have the book poor poor
charlie's almanac i think that's what
this is ripped off of which is charlie
munger
who's warren buffett's business partner
it was like about charlie munger
and so uh he tried to make you know if
naval is one of the good
great thinkers of our time then he tried
to make the compilation of all the [__]
naval said he took it from
all the times naval talked about wealth
and they pulled it all together and put
it all in one place and distilled it
down
and this book uh is broken into two
parts the first is wealth the second is
happiness i found the wealth stuff to be
a little bit boring um i don't even
remember
i i actually skipped over a lot of it i
don't even remember what he said about
wealth do you
yeah i mean i think it's it's the same
thing that that we've talked about on
here but he has this
tweet storm that went ultra ultra viral
like maybe i don't know
50 to 100 million people have seen it by
now and it's called how to get rich
without getting lucky and he talks about
these four things i i mean i can go into
it or i can skip it if you want to
talk about it a little bit yeah
basically his summary is like you know
here's some of the principles that over
you know naval's become very wealthy and
over time he sort of learned for
himself he wanted to be wealthy as a kid
because he grew up pretty poor
and he wanted to be wealthy and he
wanted to be wealthy not in a way that
required
outlier luck and he says this great
thing which is like you know i want to
if i lived life 100 times i want to end
up wealthy you know 98
uh 99 times or like if you took away all
my wealth now and you drop me you know
butt naked in in the streets of
bangalore um i want to be able to again
in five ten years end up
rich again and so that means i actually
understand the principles of how this is
done and i'm not relying on
unluck and so he talks about those
principles and he basically says
you know you want to have these like
three or four things so
first stop renting out your time you'll
never get rich renting out your time
which is
you know 90 something percent of people
are employees somewhere
you are basically renting your time to
an employer and um
you'll never become wealthy or you
rarely become wealthy
with that path uh you become wealthy by
owning a piece of a business
either as an investor or as a business
owner or as an employee who has shares
like
employees at google or facebook who have
seen you know
gotten a lot of wealth by the
appreciation of those shares and so
um then he talks about you know how do
you how do you get to that point well
you need
a few things you want um you know use
what you call specific knowledge which
is basically like
like sam you know how to grow a
newsletter you know how to write content
you know copywriting right you know
certain things and so you need specific
knowledge
then you pair that with accountability
so you want to do it in the name of the
hustle or
sam or some brand that accrues that
reputation so you want to
put your name on the line and say i'm
going to do this thing and so that when
you do it you get paid for it
you know the people at the hustle who
write your daily newsletter
but are less well known they
actually have certain skills they have
certain unique knowledge specific
knowledge
but they don't have the account they're
not putting up the accountability
they're not living and dying by the
sword of this
news that are working or not um maybe
inside the company they are but not
externally
and then you have leverage so you know
back in the day if you wrote something
you would maybe distribute it locally on
your newspaper or
on a flyer or something like that but
with the internet you have leverage
where you can put this in an email and
you can send it
you can put the same amount of work in
to write the email once you can send it
to 100 000 people a million people or 10
million people
it's the same amount of work because you
have tremendous leverage through
technology
and so basically he talks about like use
these three things
get specific knowledge be accountable
put your name on the line that way you
get the risk and the reward
and lastly apply leverage to maximize
the the value that you get out of the
thing that's kind of
the basic formula and the whole book
basically
um is broken down to this idea of
life is about health wealth and
happiness or sorry
wealth health happiness and he says we
actually pursue it
we go we pursue wealth then we do health
then we do happiness and he's like
that's actually a fine way to pursue it
it's that's a very practical and fine
way to pursue it the reality is is that
it's the reverse is true like in terms
of importance so it's happening
happiness health wealth but it's
whatever it's finding pursue that way
and he has this beautiful line in the
book where he says something like
um of course once you get the wealth
you're gonna see that it's actually not
nearly as important as you thought
but you're not gonna listen to me and
you have to pretty much
discover it on your own yeah you're not
gonna listen to me i wouldn't have
listened to me
um you know the type of person who's
attracted to this content you know they
they're going to go through the same
thing you have to learn that the hard
way
and so that was pretty interesting so i
liked that but the second half is all
about happiness and there was a few
things that kind of stuck
stuck out to me the first is that um he
basically acknowledged
he he was like look don't worry
well then let me preface this by saying
neval interests me because
he's like i mean he's probably a
billionaire i have to imagine he started
angelus which is a multi-billion dollar
company he's
an investor like he's in the game and he
acknowledges like i'm in the game and so
like this is a little bit hypocritical
but basically he was like what i found
is that a
happiness must be a choice like i've
been unhappy for decades
and then i decided you know i'm going to
be happy and he steals a lot of
philosophy from stoicism and he steals a
lot of it from buddha
buddhism and the idea here is that like
your past is unimportant
and the future is unimportant and to say
that you want to do x y and z for legacy
that's [__] because what's going to
happen is when you die
it's going to be as if you were you know
if it's the same
feeling that you had before you were
born which is like nothing so like
who cares about some [__] legacy
which is like hard to fight against
right
uh but and he's like it only matters
about the
about the present and where you are now
and that gets a little bit fluffy but i
still thought it was really
useful and oddly did you if you read the
book
he talks about not working hard he was
like you actually should only do work
that feels like play
yeah and i thought that was kind of cool
and he's like
life's too short by the way just to
grind and work your ass off which again
i'm like
button of all you're like a billionaire
like is this like what you know how do
you
i have to like kind of come to grasp it
with us a little bit
but i thought it was cool he also talks
about um
very oddly gives diet advice he's like
just don't eat sugar
stay away from sugar do high intensity
interval training
and stretch a lot yeah and he
even says he goes uh i try not to he's
like you know
i don't talk too much about health
because i'm pretty good at health i'm
okay
but i'm not self-actualized in that
meaning like in wealth he's done better
than 99.9 percent of people
uh so you know for him to talk about it
well he's self-actualized it he has
actually done it
uh for himself and seen it done by many
other people and so he feels comfortable
putting out his whole philosophy on it
he's like in terms of health like i'll
say some general things that
you you know it's hard to argue against
but i try not to talk too much about it
even though it's very important because
i myself you know for many years didn't
have an exercise routine or wasn't you
know the best eater
and now i'm better but i'm still not the
best i'm not world class at that i'm not
99.9 percent
at that one i'll i could tell one story
so i called a friend and and this is
almost like stuff i've read or listened
to in the last like
four days which is a lot but i want i i
i had a friend and this is all related
to what
this is related to what we talked about
earlier about crazy people i love
freaks and i had a friend call and tell
me about their best friend
and let me tell you this story so
there's this guy
i'm gonna change some details i don't
want to reveal it
he was an accountant and on some large
deals that he was working on
at the age of like 30 he was able to
save up
one to two million dollars i think it
was two million dollars at the age of
30. he was single
he lived relatively frugally but he
worked on some he worked at a big
company he was just an employee but he
worked on such a deal that he was able
to capture
like some of the commissions and he made
like two million bucks with that two
million dollars
he angel invested a little bit and one
of his angel investments made like half
a million dollars and so here he is
sitting with like two and a half to
three million dollars
at the age of mid 30s okay so
about last 20 months ago when was
bitcoin six thousand dollars
yeah about about a year and a half two
years ago or no sorry when it was three
thousand
whatever it was he put three million
dollars
into bitcoin everything he had
everything 100 of everything he had to
the point of like i think he like saved
like
10 000 or 20 thousand dollars for living
expenses he put most everything he had
and also he borrowed money i don't i'm
not uh he was able to borrow money
uh somehow like through like like as
simple as like robin hood gives you a
little bit of margin but he was able to
borrow money
to the point of like he was in debt a
significant amount of money
and he bought a ton of bitcoin well
last december when it hit 65 or 63
000 his 3 million
turned into around 100 million dollars
and he sold about half of it so he's got
like this cushion
and then he up and left and moved to
another country and
he lives there because he's like you
know i'm just i believe that like this
country is the future
and the point of this story is i'm not
like this crazy person i don't think you
are either
you have a family you're not going to up
and move them although
you will take interesting bets but
and i recognize i am not this human
being i am
so thankful that crazy people like this
exist
not for our amusement necessarily but
like the world need like
his boldness was like rooted in some
type of selfishness he wants to get risk
rig it rich but that type of boldness
even though this may not be the best
example
but that personality type is what pushes
society forward
and actually does weird crazy stuff that
ends up becoming normal and common for
us
right dude i don't know if i i don't
think this is uncommon
but i feel special the way i feel
special that i'm this way but
i know this is actually most people i
think
but i [__] love
uh greatness in any field like you could
just be like hey
um you play billiards i'm like no
check this out this person is the best
in the world at billiards tell me more i
stop watching them i'll watch them for
eight hours straight i'll then go watch
the documentary about them and then i'll
go find
like you know the book about them and
i'll just keep going deep because
there's something about greatness that
um
is just so like attractive to me and so
recently
uh do you watch the tv show dave of
course i like uh
what's the guy's name the rest of ricky
yeah little dicky
so dave is a show that i started
watching
and i love dave dave is like a hilarious
show to me and it's like a very unique
show right uh
and it's not like most tv shows it's not
made like most tv shows
it uses like everybody's real names it's
like kind of set in hollywood it's this
guy's story of trying to be a big rapper
which is his real story
and then it's kind of like he's not like
it's not entourage where he's just like
cool and cool [__] keeps happening
models keep throwing themselves at him
it's like
the opposite uh he's kind of like a
nerdy jewish guy who happens to be an
aspiring rapper and
you know things happen to him that are
not so great all the time and so
um i just love this dude this dude is
like
he's so talented he's very talented as a
rapper if you haven't listened to the
little dicky sway freestyle we should
put that whole freestyle
at the end of this episode dan do that
just grab the whole audio for that free
style and put it at the end of this
one where he gives the girl flowers he
gives her flowers exactly um
that freestyle is amazing although i
mean obviously it's not an actual
freestyle
and then um you know to be to then go
into like
how he marketed himself so he's a former
ad agency guy
who got his job at an agency and was
like writing a rap
song for like doritos to like win the
client win the gig when the account
then leaves to go become an actual
rapper he his story is kind of like he
uh he works for a long time on his album
doesn't show anyone has no results to
show for it
kind of like runs out of time and money
doing this and then like launches his
first music video and it like goes viral
and
because he had put so much work into his
craft of like making this work
and he's completely authentic right so
like back to a navalism
escape competition through authenticity
most of the things you want occur in
very competitive spaces
and the answer is not to try to
out-compete everybody
by being better because everybody's
trying to be better the way to do it is
to be different
the way to be different the easiest way
to be different is to be completely you
because nobody can be better at you than
you you've been you your whole life you
have a lifetime of experience at it
and so similarly for dave uh he his
niche
in rapping is like being you know an
awkward white guy
rapper just kind of growing through life
trying to get with women and failing
sometimes and sometimes succeeding and
et cetera et cetera um and so i think
this guy is so impressive to me and so i
love
finding these like you know whether it's
in the ufc that's why i love conor
mcgregor and
his rise because early on i was like
this guy seems like he's
full of greatness and then you see it
play out and you're like wow that was
amazing
uh dave in the rap scene so this look
and you're talking about this with
edison
and some of the books that you can naval
like some of the the content you're
consuming
um i don't know like what do you think
are we kind of like
are we unique in this or is this i feel
like everybody loves greatness right
but is there something different i don't
think it's the same i i think that
i think it's because we have a privilege
we've been privileged
in that you and i have seen people who
have we have seen like
dozens of people accomplish things that
a
most people like like hear rumors about
or movies about like no i know this
person they
and a lot of them it's financial but you
know they sold their company they made
500 million dollars like
we know many people have done that and
so we like we first hand know like man
greatness is real and you could
self-actualize we know it's real
the second thing is we know people that
have created or invented or worked on
things
that everyone else takes for granted and
you're like dude you have no idea what
it takes to
like uh to have like made that a reality
it just it's so impressive and i think
that
um because of that yeah we like
appreciate
bold people who are also capable right
and so
i think a lot of people are like that
but not that many people for example
when i go to a convenience store and
there's like a sign taped to the door
i'm like do you have any [__] pride
fix that [__]
like put a proper frame like do this the
right way it'd like
be the best that's why i test you to
test lack of greatness
i can't stand that but like but you know
there's a reason why like we're not the
only ones there's a reason why
jiro what's that jiro love sushi or zero
sushi yeah
yeah like or like nike nike's old
marketing is not about the rubber in
their shoes it's about like great
athletes because everybody loves great
athletes uh that's the easy one that
everybody loves
no i i i but i like it like when i look
at like i don't care about weightlifting
but i look weightlifter i'm like dude
the gay
look how this guy's like weighing his
food every single day and getting up at
5 30 like
just for the like i just i i love that
um
so we'll um let me move on to one more
thing but
uh yeah i do i love greatness and i'll
tell you these last two things that i've
read
one point on that i would say definitely
a lot of good has come
has come from being a fan of greatness
um
but i would say try to be a fan of
greatness not a fan of the people
um and the reason i say that is because
what often happens is when people get
really into greatness they go study
these people and then they
they're in their net conclusion is wow
they're great
and they're different than me and i they
sort of like separate it's almost like
oh that's a different species
um and there's a there's a way to do
this that's better which is basically
you take you get entertainment and
inspiration from them and education from
them of the things that they do
but like don't count yourself as
something different
treat yourself like that's that's you
you're them you're you're no different
than them they are just like you they're
just you know made of the same things as
you
had the same doubts as you had the same
insecurities as you had the same
struggles as you
and uh and so like don't like create
this divide
of the great people and then you because
then it's counterproductive
then every time you you learn about
their greatness it reinforces
this kind of like negative perception of
yourself instead if you think about
yourself just like them
then every time you learn about them it
creates a positive reinforcement about
what you can also do and i'll tell you
just the last few things that i consumed
this week that made a difference
the first is not or the last couple
non-violent communication
it's real touchy feely you know what
non-violent communication is
i've never read it but i've heard about
it yeah yeah it's a way to speak
uh in a way i guess i don't know how
would you explain it
basically i have a problem like i suck
at dealing with people
like my emotions get the best of me i
get angry at people
and i communicate stuff and i'm like why
am i getting angry like this is so
counterproductive
i do this with sarah i've done it with
you before i've done it with all my
co-workers
i just communicate horribly so i'm
actually trying to learn a better way to
communicate a more effective way to
communicate
and this is like giving you a toolkit so
it's basically like it just gives you
like
a better way to talk to people so you
can give us one nugget from it so
what's one tweak dude it's really hard
it's like
like it's so opposite of how i do things
so if for example like like there's like
a
like okay so the there's a lot someone
who's an expert on this is gonna like
criticize me and how am i explaining it
but it's quite complicated for me
because it's so
not normal but basically the idea here
is like look i'm not gonna judge you
for you telling me this i'm not going to
get angry i'm not going to judge you but
i actually just want to clarify
like so you feel like this correct okay
well what i need from you is x y and z
are you able to like are we able to can
i get that from you or no
and then it's like that type of like
very like crystal clear
and then like you'll say things like
look can you repeat back what you
thought i said
so for example um i'll tell you to do
something
and i'll say and you'll say okay fine
i'll be like can you repeat back
well you said if you don't do this
you're going to yell it or you
let me find a better example okay my
wife and i
we got into like an argument over i
forget what we got into an argument over
but i said um can you repeat back to me
what you thought i said
well you said it's gonna piss you off if
you if i do this again and i was like
no i actually didn't mean to express the
idea of i'm gonna be angry at you it was
just like it hurts my feelings
when this happens right you know what i
mean so it's a different it's a
different way to communicate i'm not
good at it this is why i'm reading this
[__] book clearly i can barely
describe
the damn thing the last thing or the
second to last thing
the courage to be disliked great book i
started getting into it
um because after naval and it's just
like
there's a few takeaways here i'll read
the my four takeaways the first is it's
dangerous to believe that your passive
term is your future
i know it's fluffy if you focus on
what's wrong with you you might be
looking for reasons to hate yourself on
purpose
again fluffy third most of what we think
is competition is just
made up and is hurting your happiness
and four this is like
crazy woo-woo basically life is just a
bunch of like sounds
and lights and like the emotion we
assign emotion to it and so you don't
actually like you can assign a happy
emotion
so that's the last one and then the last
article i read that made a big
difference
there's this new yorker article written
in 2014 about sam altman have you ever
read this
maybe i i like to study sam altman but i
haven't i don't
remember this one it's written in 2016 a
new yorker it's called sam altman's
manifest destiny and i was rereading
this and
i want to tell you a few reasons first
in 2016 he talks about
this they ask him what his hobbies are
and what he does when he's not working
he goes
uh i like racing cars i like renting
planes and flying them
oh and i've got one odd thing that i
like i like to prep for prep for
survival
seeing their be bolderment he explained
my problem
sorry i'm butchering this the problem is
when my friends get drunk they talk
about ways the world will end
after a dutch lab modified h5n1 bird flu
viruses
five years ago making it super
contagious the chance of lethal
virus being released the next 20 years
will become well
non-zero so i have
a plot of land in big sur that i can fly
to
i have antibiotics batteries water
gas mass made by israel defense force
all ready to go
this was in 2016. that's kind of cool
right
he also talks about basically he sold
his company and he uh he goes he
profited five million and he invested
all of it in startups which i thought
was pretty crazy because we're talking
about like crazy freaks
um it's just a really good article i
think people should read this because
sam altman is like a freak weirdo
and that's like a compliment um because
we're talking about extreme
personalities and i think it's like a
really cool
insight and it's one of the only article
long-form articles i've ever seen
written about them so i've been
rereading that
this week that's a cool one i'm going to
check that out i remember paul graham
had once said something
and paul is obviously a fan of sam alban
because he programmed star y combinator
and then he put
sam altman in charge of it um and sam
altman was by no means the most
successful yc
alumni at the time i think his company
sold for 30 million but it was kind of
like
many ways of failure it didn't succeed
it raised 40 and it
sold for 30. yeah exactly um and so i
think he got some out of it but you know
whatever
but uh paul graham once said like he's
like when i was talking to sam altman i
think maybe for the first time or second
time he's like
i had this thought oh this is what it
would have been like to talk to bill
gates at 21.
and like that's like pretty high praise
for somebody so i i thought that was
like a pretty cool
um i don't know pretty cool description
pretty cool yeah and there's
there's a lot of weird things about
altman that i love i should come up with
a better word than weird but peculiar
things so for example listen to the
sentence in a class that altman taught
at stanford in 2014 so which by the way
in 2014 he must have been like 28.
he remarked that the formula for
estimating a startup's chance of success
is something like
idea times product times execution
times team times luck where luck is a
random number between zero and ten
thousand
and like like little lines like that i
just think it's crazy that someone
thinks like that
and it's just it's peculiar it's
exciting it's really neat there's
another story
where he um he's working with the with
brian chesky the ceo of airbnb
and they're about to pitch in front of
everyone at uh yc
and there's this great line where he
says brian chessy goes i attribute a lot
of our success
uh to sam altman and yc and they're like
well why he was like well
right before our deck uh they we had a
limited
we had our deck it was all built out we
had limited our projected revenue on the
deck to 30 million dollars
chesky said sam stopped us and looked at
us and goes
do me a favor take all those m's you
know the 30 million
and change them to bees altman recalls
telling them
either you don't believe everything you
said in the rest of the deck about how
big this is going to be
or you're ashamed or i just can't do
math yeah
and he just said change all the ends to
bes and i think like that weird type of
thinking is actually pretty interesting
yeah people who can cut through the
noise and just like get straight to the
heart of it um
all right this is cool this is kind of
like stuff that sam's been
reading and listening to stuff we've
been consuming i don't know
is this interesting is this going to be
good or true i enjoyed the conversation
i don't know dan what do you think is
this gonna be a good pod
yeah i think it's cool i think it'd be a
fun thing to check in every couple weeks
or a month
all right well let's see but that's the
episode lil dicky
it's your turn to rock wonder drop a
beat on them
and i'm back in this [__] i know y'all
know when i rap what it is all facts
don't fib got a gang full of hits in
touch with the kids like a pedo
i'm a jam like shaq i'm a bang when i
wish up in this [__] like a feeder
ain't no timelines when you timeless
hold up
mj 96 me and i'm back on my [__] you
know i come hard like a full dick
suburban and white stay with the bread
like some cool whip though look how it's
spread
cool with flow i can make them right
with the ig live and my girl got bombs
on her body hot and between her legs is
looking right hypotenuse
break it all down hold up sway let me
bring it all down been out here
citizenship look at how i got everybody
tuned in right now they'll probably
watch this for an hour
tracy i brought you flour
gas out the ass like flatulence i was
slept on like mattresses i got my head
right aspirant i'm cashing it i'm
cashing in i'm not about to hold the
paper and display it like a thumb tack
no touch back there bout to run his back
and if you ever met me you're root for
me sharp [__] come on i'm a dome i'm a
unicorn
part of my breath only perky said i [__]
with his breasts elevated kiss and holds
it to ritz
freaky friday i get in i'm like chris
wait sway pass me the ride
get it post jab up fake huh jump into
them two shots at the line
i got em like a mime odell vega might
cut on a dime glow in the dark see me
anytime
used to put the xbox controller on my
dick and let it vibrate how i jerk off
as a child came a long way
now i'm like hey girl you me [__] and it
[__] work
hey her brother looking at me like hey
[__] bro
sway her brother looking at me like hey
i'm like kareem abdul kareem
abdul-jabbar
these hooks got me scoring see me coming
from afar
rapping in france i never need an
advance i'm switching it up like i'm
trans
although i'm the trojan man i'm eating a
[__] like cervical cancer
i know where i'm going but [__] if my
gps died i sleep in my sedan
i can't do the schmurder dance i get
caught up looking awkward
does it work for you sometimes i'll
catch it for a minute oj with it y'all
wonder how i did it my mind hit me once
she lug it in sue but i'll stomp you all
out like i'm done
sue all the shoe brands wanted me to
sign i remember they thought i was
lonely island there will not be another
like me i could go viral if i put out a
snippet i'm sick like a coder you really
could get it i'll always be playing just
like i'm embedded
i got a leg up like ottomans though my
television show is coming but that is
irrelevant right now i'm rapping like
present skit
how did i get here i got big rapping
like diddy i'm prevalent
hold up let me find a melody all my fans
are getting mad at me
they just want to hear me spazzing now
but i just had to put a couple smashers
out
how is this [__] a pop star rap name is
a dick joke
how did he make it that far good [__]
at the crib like a house cat
they're waiting on my buzz like the
outback in and out with the bag like i
make tea
when i do shopping sprees eyebrows long
like a d
girls getting wet like navy polo like
i'm stefan shoe cream
players in the nba text me if i want a
diet coke
someone brings me diet coke on my life
shows
nuts like our exposed testicles hold up
wait let me add live my [__]
oh yeah yeah look at my penmanship i
write this i'm a carl's jr model for
real
just on the side like soccer moms i
could have sold you stocking bonds
having so fast like ramadan the autobahn
the shaman running down the bomb from
carson's arm i'm off to farm i'm on the
court the jumbotron is on the boy they
playing my song lebron is nodding
am i james worthy look at my bars all
made up like bernie
oh we having fun girls see me and start
blushing just because i'm around
i used to always get a boner at my
physical sway
if this is cultural appropriation what
can i say
what would you have me do you know i got
a rap but the times now are scary hold
up
wait take a step back they think about
this [__] internet is a permanent place
this is going to live forever
breathe analyze think about everything
i'm such an idiot i used to cover art
kelly songs at my shows without even
knowing it was problematic
i feel the pressure under more scrutiny
what i do act more jewishly
come on sway write my eulogy am i
looking like i need to get a job
or looking like i need a bodyguard i
play tennis with leonardo how ya'll
train on track like cargo i go
dumb don't dumb it up don't [__] on
planes but i'm coming up add up my views
to sum it up i was just on sports center
i think this is good i've done enough my
haters look mad like son of a
now let me go and finish on my album
jesse smolet you know i'ma [__] it up
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
the one and only lil dicky ladies and
gentlemen
your man or your word
[Applause]
[Music]
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back